dans les différentes communautés
musulmanes on a suivi de près la sphère
de l'imam hamza chaoui beaucoup ne se
reconnaissent pas dans ses dires comme
ses propos sur l'incompatibilité de
l'islam avec la démocratie que l'islam
est contre la démocratie ça signifie
pour moi dire que l'islam et pour la
dictature
ce qui est faux azzedine mba et imams et
président du centre bell agir un centre
spirituel musulmans et fait son doctorat
en études religieuses à l'université
concordia
il nous explique qu'il n'existe pas
vraiment de critères pour être imam dans
l'islam sunnite
n'importe qui théoriquement n'importe
qui peut se proclamer qu'ils m'aiment
par contre il ya des conditions
d'abord il ya des conditions en ce qui
concerne l'information religieuse mais
également sa crédibilité et éthiques
certains comparent les imams comme rama
chaoui à des évangélistes ou des
prédicateurs qu'il n'y a pas vraiment de
contrôle ni de hiérarchie chez les
musulmans sunnites
c'est très libérale c'est à dire que les
gens s'ils trouvent qu'un imam il n'est
pas capable de remplir sa mission et ils
peuvent par exemple le changer chez les
musulmans chiites il faut que l'imam
soir ferrée par une autorité religieuse
l'imam nabil abbas a été désigné par le
grand ayatollah sistani d'irak pour être
son représentant au canada diront cinq
ans je faisais beaucoup d'études
religieuses et après
je suis vimont et hydro beyrouth au
liban pour dix ans ici au centre
islamique libanais les hommes et les
femmes a pris ensemble
selon la porte-parole carmen chouinard
un imam doit répondre à des qualités
précises faut être imam et foucque que
ta réputation soient intègres se dire
qu'on a rien qui veut tout est entachée
ensuite il faut que tu sois connaissant
le plus connaissant carmen chouinard
s'est converti à l'islam chiite
il y à une quinzaine d'années ne se
reconnaît pas non plus dans les
déclarations d'anne d'achat oui je
promets un islam très ouvert je prends
un islam ou les où les droits de l'homme
en priorité sur tout autre chose
quant à la radicalisation des jeunes
pour beaucoup c'est une affaire
d'éducation
le jeune qui avait tissé à montréal il
peut se radicaliser en se muant des
vidéos youtube qui ont été produits par
exemple au pakistan il affirme qu
interdire à shawi d'ouvrir son centre ne
changera pas grand-chose à jabot de
l'eger guise radio canada montréal